the dingy touch sure on the Pebble Beach
at Kings down near deal early Sunday
morning six Iranian Nationals got off
and apparently waited at the local bus
stop Border Agency staff arrived on the
scene but it took them a while to find
the group two guys came along in a Coast
Guard
jeep Land Rover kind of thing and they
said them have you seen a group of men
walking around us at nine seen anyone
and they said we're far to go and I said
we're right way down as far as I could
and they said all we're looking for four
guys had just come off an inflatable
which one to find them the men were
given a medical assessment and
transferred for immigration processing
the latest in nearly a hundred migrants
who have crossed the channel on these
flimsy boats since Christmas by
lunchtime patrons at the beachside pub
the zetlen arms were discussing the
situation I just feel sad that these
people are really desperate and this
families out there that wanted some
shelter and it's really really sad
obviously these people are so desperate
that they're trying to get over here you
know we've all been enjoying our
Christmases with our families we're
going to be wreck sitting in a few weeks
time apparently and we're meant to be I
mean closing our borders or whatever and
they don't seem to be the resources to
to to police our borders there's one
Coast Guard Cutter who they're gonna
have to spend a lot more money on they
think we should be investing more in
that yeah if you're gonna if you're
gonna police your borders there are
fears it's only a matter of time before
a group is killed in the channel from a
capsized dinghy the Home Secretary Sajid
Javid says the journeys are reckless
attempts being made in unsafe boats and
treacherous conditions the seas are by
no means perfect right now for striking
out from France and heading for this
dramatic coastline but that didn't deter
this latest group from taking that risk
Kingsdown beach where the men were found
is just a few miles south of dear marine
traffic maps show a UK border force
vessel has been scanning the waters from
Folkston to Ramsgate paying particular
attention to waters near Dover on Sunday
afternoon we filmed it anchored off the
coast of deal.this the only border
agency Carter in the UK channel some MPs
won the agency's for other cutters
deployed here the defense sector II says
the Navy is standing by to help but
after a call with his French counterpart
Sajid Javid announced the two countries
would be stepping up joint patrols and
increasing surveillance this
announcement today looks a bit like a
delayed reaction Labour's been warning
since the autumn when the numbers of
these perilous crossings has been
escalating that we can't cut back on our
border forces security services in the
channel conservative government hasn't
listened to this they've steamrollered
ahead
the Home Secretary will meet his french
opposite number in January and there's
pressure for a formal arrangement that
people who arrived on these shores by
boat are sent back to France most claim
asylum here but under international
agreements many could be returned UK
traditionally hasn't needed to return
that many asylum seekers to other
European countries because for the most
part people who were seeking asylum in
the UK arrived by plane so what is
particularly different about the new
arrivals is is the mode of arrival the
fact that they are actually being
intercepted in the channel there is
sympathy from locals here that people
are desperate enough to risk their lives
to get here but also concern that the
numbers doing it are rising
Jason Farrell Sky News Dover